nein ich denke die ganze das von
irgendwo ein ding kommt oder so fakt
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zurück zu einer
neuen folge kohlen befreiungs einheit
kurz gesagt geh ich habe mich nun ein
wenig informiert und gibt mir
unglaublich massenhaft in die kommentare
geschrieben was auch bedeutet dass ihr
euch darüber auch informiert habe
worüber ich euch natürlich sehr dankbar
bin wie ich denn dieses rätsel lösen
kann und ich war ja so blöd irgendwie
war es klar dass ich das sage aber
schauen wir mal einfach hier rein
hier ist ein gang und schon mal was da
ist da ist ist der code lautet nur sind
diese sechs prozent unter das hashtag
dann hältst du es hier eigentlich
unsagbar geheimnis versteckte kann mir
erst mal nachgucken was ist das hier das
wahrscheinlich ein smaragd
auch hier sind die restlichen smaragde
sehe ich gerade code 1 faszinierend auch
jetzt ergibt sich ja alles seinen sinn
noch so okay das sind die sachen an
das nochmal code 1 und das co2 naja
zurück kommt auf jeden fall erstmal
nicht mehr
der dsds problem da hinten sind ja noch
unsere neuen charakter drin
und naja jedenfalls hatte ich letztes
mal das problem dass mir die map einfach
so komplett gelöscht
deswegen habe ich jetzt größtenteils
versuchen die sachen zurück zu holen
ab hinten die 19 wieder reingelegt und
alles so gut noch mal durchgespielt ohne
dass aufzunehmen also na ja das war
schon eine heidenarbeit also et dann die
striche also oben links okay dann ist
das hier der erste code dass das das und
das
ok ok das einst markt und der zweite
code war doch an die heute zurücksetzen
zu setzen so der zweite code mal dass
das das und das
und da haben wir die glas bottles mit
den schwarzen also der sebastian der map
erstellt mit aber auch ein wenig
geholfen und irgendwie will ich jetzt
ich will meine sachen da zurück diese
doofen smaragde da na ja also wir merken
uns wir haben in dem ein ding star 9 zum
arag täterin kommt zurück so ach so hier
sind auch noch die marke cube ist drin
ganz einfach weil wie gesagt ich hab mir
das geschieht weil ich auf worin das so
blöd aufgenommen hatte aber dann schmeiß
ich hier von einfach vier in müll also
die map war komplett weg von daher würde
ich sagen akzeptiert das bitte ich meine
es jetzt kennen schicken oder so die
rüstung bobbys mutter randys maroc
dating brown kann ich das hier nicht
irgendwie ich habe keinen plan wie man
sachen braut versteht
dezember trank das sind das okay
so dass sie irgendwie
hier geht auch nicht dann brauchen wir
wasser
die antwort ach so wartet die kann ich
als wenn wir da hinten sondern was
allerdings gehabt das kann ich da doch
einfach mal so jetzt habe ich in water
bottles es hänge ich noch was drin hier
waren nie was drin
jetzt gehe ich hierhin markiert die
models rainer-marc frey creme fraiche
also ich mach das auch mal ich hab mir
ich hab ja auch johnson bringt stand
oben in der küche stehen und immer wenn
ich dann mal eben zur schule durch lava
schwimmen will dann mache ich eine water
bottle bei uns im privaten pool
vollgepackter der magma cream oben drauf
und dann habe ich das auch so hier ist
jetzt auch noch effekt drauf jetzt packt
aber nicht aber ich habe keine ahnung
was ich überhaupt noch
also da steht ja da steht meter marke
cube seltsam trank seltsame trank
21 was höhe selbst krank ist so das ist
nummer 1 und nummer 2
nur eins ist das wie kann ich da
einpacken
das ist ein 2 und das ist nummer 1 bot
pushen aber nichts von den beiden bringt
mir doch was oder
ich meine ich lager die sachen hier erst
mal ganz kurz und trinkt mir hier von
einer explosion und den puschen
achso zuerst lassen dann muss ich mark
cuban bestimmt haben schon alle in die
kommentare geschrieben dass ich also
total blöd wahrheit geht das ja all
seinen sinn so du fährst erstmal darüber
discard wisst ihr was ich habe jetzt
noch eben eine an wenn das ein ende hat
es dann kommt dann kriege ich die
smaragde wahrscheinlich gleich da hinten
wieder das dann natürlich eine gute
sache übrigens nämlich gerade mit dx
tore auf und nicht mit fraps und audi
city so wie ich das sonst noch erwartet
zurück nicht dass das nicht wenn ich das
vielleicht auch irgendwie nicht überlebe
dann packe ich ihn ja noch die magma
krebs rein und eventuell werde ich auch
bald ein tutorial zu dick story machen
schreibt dann einfach in die kommentare
ob er das sehen wollte wie lange habe
ich das jetzt 23 minuten oder coole
funktioniert interessant alles blau und
hamm unter der lava gegenstand sei wie
in meine sachen zurück
ich bin jetzt erst mal noch ein bisschen
so vor mich hin ich finde es richtig
finde ich finde ich sehr season in the
turtle komponenten labor könnte ich
vielleicht mal aufhören zu brennen das
wäre echt allerliebst
so okay ich habe aufgehört jetzt wird's
global noch so was ist das hoch runter
dings das ist eine lampe blinky pinky
der ruf der einheit auf zu stück bling
bling komponente ok cool hier ist die
kiste instruktion gbs person sie sind
nützlich wir haben ihnen dieser
schreiben zukommen lassen um ihnen
mitzuteilen dass sie noch weitere golems
befreien müssen viel glück ihr boss
golems wird groß geschrieben so okay da
oben kann man nicht hoch ist die tür
komme ich aber auch nicht rein
ok das heißt wir müssen nur irgendwie
noch weitere golems befreit
lasst mich doch da könnte theoretisch so
machen einfach fällt mir darauf warum
kompliziert wenn es auch ein neues da um
diese bilder dieses blöde relevanter
also viel frische luft hier ist nichts
in dem gang oder wahrscheinlich wieder
ganz viele smaragde die wir übersehen
haben
aber wir haben ja nun die 13 diamanten
gefunden die man als zwischen links
haben sollte jetzt sind wir hier in
berlin wir sind darunter ok kommen
irgendwie kiste oder so ach jetzt bin
ich hier drin
roland freilassen nähe irgendwie glaube
ich nicht dass man den darf rein lassen
kann oder
doch funktioniert ich dachte es wäre
dann irgendwie sterben das ist eine
falle werde so naja so bett bett nacht
machen das finde ich echt geil dass
dieses nacht machen hier ist weil ich
weiß noch als ich
was habe ich denn da gespielt das war
ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz ganz damals in
seine jump'n'run web und da musste ich
immer times 20.000 machen zum labor des
schmerzes grüne linie folgen
man versteht hier unsere lustigste
erfindung der tränen stein zum heulen
komisch nicht war doch sehr witzig von
stück versteinerte goldzähne und
eingeschmolzen des brief gold unsere
preisgekrönte erfindung rost satz für
den gebrauch in heim und garten von
kindern und bürokraten fernhalten
unsere langweiligsten kohle ist doch
unsere kultsendung gammastrahlen blockt
alles ab wir sollten nur das glas durch
alles ersetzen was die strahlung
eindämmt bruder gehe ich lieber weiter
weg unsere neueste erfindung die rote
von silvio sagt röthlin aber wir
arbeiten dran
freue dich okay labor des schmerzes
monotone gänge dagegen kann man etwas
tun du hast die entscheidung ich
entweder links oder rechts war richtig
geil jetzt alter der raum liegt leider
manchmal kurze foto king zwischen foto
balasz aber längst immer die schrift
stehen
dafür schaut pasta auf dem tisch
okay was haben wir da vor gott nicht ich
muss jetzt lieber phil brown
hallo zusammen hier das hallenbad stand
große lego polypen sehr gruselig in
diesem bereich steigt eine coole zum 5
yeah
ich bin doch cool so warte seminar labor
des schmerzes je besser wir lava schmerz
grad a++ realität simulation
wachenleiter roman schwer zu erhalten es
ist schon krass
dieser gewohnheit des c4 1 811 die muss
er ein oder wie schublade schublade
schublade wenn er darum hier sieht auch
wieder richtig geil gebaut aus tnt
schmerz grafik sowie exporte
keine ahnung hier ist alles in luft
geflogen
und hier ist endlich mal was wir auch
machen können kompakte drei mal drei
pisten tür der welt kompakt ist also und
da caquetá schmerz grad 4 so gern mal
ein
ohne hier wurde ein blog vergessen wie
peinlich schöner raum ist hier dass ein
langer gang ist ein schalter ich bin
geil wie kräftig knopfdruck nicht das
sind ja man gibt mir mehr
na gut
ach was wir hier
euro einer leiter
m
ok
da sind die diamanten bringt das
a
hiermit den geben wir bekannt dass das
wort und den vorsätzen und nächsten
nicht vorverlegt wird zusätzlich etwas
geöffnet oder so erst mal hier in
smaragd und hört sich geöffnet höre ich
gerade sell order der datenträger hier
ist nichts natur pur das hier ist himmel
knopf knopf ich finde ihn zu decken
viel mehr spaß am arbeitsplatz denn
gründeln den dritten punkt
da muss ich dann wahrscheinlich mal so
laufen oder
hat man was verändern wo es überhaupt
diese rote ding hier wenn das da hinten
das heißt er muss ich erst hier darauf
laufen also erst auf das grüne dann
hilft es die landen dann auf das rote
und auf das blaue
nein verdammt die pin zu langsam nein
verdammt viel zu langsam
nein
brandstätter zu langsam
nein hundertmal vernünftiger start